uh
good good evening uh members agenda item
one
uh chairman notices
um
i'd like to welcome you to this meeting
of the council on the 25th of
august
my name is councillor boyce and i'm
chairman of the council
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present to them in the meeting you are
giving your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the youtube livestream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can i ask that when when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please remember to turn on all your
microphones and turn it off when
finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your contribution
as clear and concise as possible
thank you members agenda item 2
apologies for absence miss byrd
thank you agenda item 3 declaration of
interest
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interest other
registerable interests and
non-registrable interests relating to
the items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 8 and and
appendix b of the code of conduct for
members
and you are reminded that they are all
you are also required to disclose any
such interests as soon as they become
you become aware
should you read the need arise
throughout the meeting
members interest council of stamps
gentlemen i'm going to have to ask
despite the training session this
afternoon and i've brought the notes
um and i'm still none otherwise thank
you councillor fluker and i'd just like
to declare i'm a member of essex county
council um there's no items on the
agenda but i'm not sure which one it is
so i was going to ask the question today
um
i forgot your name
mr welch but um i ran out of time and
it's like a non-pecuniary but the
equivalent of that so i'll be guided by
the monitoring officer chairman please
um well it's your declaration
but i've just asked the guy i told the
monitoring office i wanted him down at
the end of the way out of the way
uh
uh mr quelch
can you help councillor stamp
um i think i can
um
it if there is an agenda there's no need
to declare your membership of essex
county council if there's no agenda item
relevant for that body but if there is
then it will be an other registrable
interest
because that will be in part two of your
form because essex county council is a
body
that is influencing
um that has that that has public uh
public responsibilities public duties
chairman so i've got no interest
counselor durham
here's your lead well
germany i was just going to say is if
there is one it would be another
registerable interest but um
so be it i will declare it at the the
interests of openness and transparency
council of fleming
thank you chair uh the same a
registerable interest as a member of
essex county council thank you thank you
any other member
no right
uh now we go to agenda item 4 which here
says uh notice of uh of motion uh now
we we
are sort of having a combined thing here
because this is an extraordinary general
extraordinary meeting of the council at
the request of several members
and we're working to emotions proposed
by councillor lagan councillor lagan
thank you mr chairman um again firstly
i'd just like to thank yourself and
officers for uh this extraordinary
meeting that was requested by 16 members
over half the council so i appreciate
the um the effort and the work that's
gone in my offices as well
um i'll read the motion it's probably um
simple so that anybody is listening can
can understand it so it's notice of
motion pages five to eight in accordance
with the notice duly given under
procedural four to receive the following
motion from councillors as fluka and kmh
lagan respectively
little one that a working group is
established to consider the five-year
housing land supply and the
recommendations from this working group
come back to full council for
ratification
and little two that the working group
consists of three conservative three
independent group and three non-aligned
members plus one person who is not a
member of malden district council
therefore i submit a motion uh right
thank you uh is that seconded
uh do you wish to speak now or reserve
your speech for later
much later i hope chum well i'm hoping
it's not much later because this seems
to me to be quite a straightforward
issue
uh
does any member wish to speak at this
time
councillor stamp chairman um i've got an
amendment so shall i wait until
everybody's spoken to her i'll be guided
by you but i'd like to amend the motion
uh which part one or two
um i would like to amend
two right well for the moment then can i
put
little one
to the meeting for approval or otherwise
okay so those in favor
of the um
those two but that's not all you're
right to speak
uh councillor florika well
um
chairman before i do i just wanted to
seek your guidance um i was gonna
propose an additional uh
uh motion so it would be an amendment
but it would be in addition to one or
two i think you can propose you can
propose an amendment uh if it's a vibe
of a viable amendment um
but at the moment oh we'll just get the
council agreement to a set up a working
group
is that is that is that the green
everybody happy with that
no sorry chairman because
my amendment speaks to number one roman
one
my amendment
is that we uh
we agree that wording but in addition
that the working group also considers
the procedures used by officers
to initially approve
and recommend development sites
following the call for science i don't
think that would be a valid amendment
well then it would go as a motion to
counsel because it changes in my view of
i'll refer to the monitoring officer it
changes the the notice of motion and the
other question uh has councillor lagan
agreed to this amendment yes chairman
yes oh sorry he can speak for himself of
course
yes i have mr chairman thank you um
uh
uh mr quelch um is that a valid
amendment could could council repeat his
amendment
so
this would be in addition to one um
although
in my mind i think we should take it as
three
um that the working group also considers
the procedures the procedures used by
officers
to initially approve and recommend
development sites
following the call for science process
and and chairman the reason
why i'm tabling this is is that this
this motion that we've tried to bring
before council is started as something
completely different and this is where
it ended up
and i think there's a
quite valid reasons for that chairman
but i think that members that have been
on this council for any length of time
will remember that when we looked at the
old ep last time members were very very
much involved right from the beginning
to the point of and i can hear my friend
to the right agreeing um to the point
german where we looked at sites we
looked at where we wanted to have
development we looked at the principle
of development did we want that one
large development and i can remember we
had elongated discussions for quite some
time and i'm sure you'll remember i do
on pepper potty i do so on pepper
potting and we seem to have
we have seen seem to have lost that
opportunity chairman and one of the
fundamental reasons for members to be
elected to this council is to place
shape to shape this district and i
believe chairman that that opportunity
has gone right well thank you
i i
i have um
some concerns about that but uh mr welch
thank you chairman um i i agree with you
chairman that
that is a different motion
it's it's it's um
the core for sites is really unrelated
to the five-year housing land supply so
what should have happened is council of
lucas should have put in a rule for
motion
uh because it's a completely separate
subject
i'd look i agree with the monitor
officer and i know that you have the
final word but i think if one goes back
through the email trail
behind this motion but as i said
chairman i'll bring forward another
motion
council can we assume that the working
group when established
will be able to take whatever evidence
it wishes to take
well kevin i think only if we agree the
terms of reference tonight and i don't
see where that is
in this report council
oh yeah thank you chairman i would
consider that particular
ocean idea
would actually come to the terms of
reference of the local development plan
policy group
rather than this working group so it
should it's part of that process it's
part of that working group it's part of
their terms of reference so i can see
what council fuku is saying and perhaps
as an item on that working group needs
to be that we we look at those sites
yeah as a way of getting around this
so that that could be an agenda item
at that particular working group
you allow me to come back look i i'm
agreeing with what everybody's saying
well i think i think
my advice and counselor civil i think uh
is basically agreeing with what i uh
with the advice of the monitoring
officer have said
um it would be better served by the
working group taking this evidence
calling for this evidence itself
um
right councillor lagan
thank you chair um would it be would be
advantageous if we actually looked at
the working groups terms of reference
well again that's not part of the motion
um i
um again uh mr quell could or or mr
dodson could you uh advise uh me please
well
chairman i mean
there is an officer response report
which
maybe chairman you feel will be
appropriate for mr dodson to explain
that because that you a working group
should really have terms of reference
and the the officer's
recommendation for
the terms of reference fits within the
motion of counselor lager
so if you think that that will be a good
thing because uh there needs to be some
some terms of reference yeah that's
little recommendation little three in
that report
members
um so uh at the present can we stick
with the motion as as proposed
and
i'll not take a vote on on little one at
the moment but we'll we'll go on to the
little
uh two
um council stan
yes chairman i'd like to amend put a
proposal forward if anybody seconds it
that the working group doesn't consist
of three conservatives three
independents three and three non-aligned
members i'd like to propose because it
is important and i think as many members
should be involved as possible and i do
take on board that not everybody likes
big working groups or large working
groups i'd like to propose it's four
conservatives for independents four
non-aligned and the independent person
does anybody second that
that seems to be uh seconded so that's a
uh
a valid uh amendment
um i'll take a vote on uh deputy leader
would you like to uh make any comment at
this stage
thank you chairman um
my comment would
be i can support the ball
but i have reservations in any case
about the independent person
who
i can't see there's any sign of any
independence i don't even know who it
might be or who we might be choosing
from at the moment
so for that reason i
couldn't support that i mean i i've
heard names mentioned in several places
but i in my view there would need to be
due um
due process to appoint such a person we
can't just have someone plonked on it
and in fact i don't think it should be
someone who's not a member of the
council at all i don't think we should
have it
mrs
mrs stamp or councillor stan uh would
you be happy to make your amendment just
referring to four four and four and for
the time being leave the independent
person on
no chairman i think uh we can go through
the process to have the independent
person and it can be um open
um as long as members don't think it's
going to delay the process that's the
only thing and and i'll take ca
counselor mr dodson's looking at me and
if you'd like to speak i can say why
yeah counselor sudo
uh thank you chairman i i agree with
councillor thompson uh yeah i can see
the need to seek expert advice and i
think that's part of what the working
group should be but this vague
independent person from who knows where
and who knows what uh yeah to me this is
unconstitutional
this is a working group for council
members and therefore it should just
consist of council members so i i can
see in the report that the officers
recommend that we seek advice externally
and we look for experts to bring that
advice but in terms of an independent
person who we do not know
i can't agree to that yeah council is
fine
thank you gentlemen i mean
a bit of a confusion here because um
we um
look like we're going to be voting on
the motion and then we've got the terms
of reference as part of the
recommendations of the officers which we
will be voting on and we want to ensure
that there isn't some conflict yeah um
to vote on having setting up the working
group and then we perhaps should look at
the terms of reference i entirely agree
with the
um what the officers and the and what mr
quote said uh relating to this other
person this outside person and that is
including that is not a good idea but if
one looks at terms of reference then we
can um
i would actually propose that we amend
the term professional to expert
because i think that allows um but that
is further down the line when we come to
vote on some support i think i think
there is a suggestion of terms of
reference within the officers report
counselor durham
thank you i i agree with the deputy
leader and councillor siddal i i just
failed to understand what an independent
person
a person off the street or a parish
council or whoever it is not a member of
here what they're going to bring to it
now the five-year land supply
and its calculation is a technical
exercise with
should be a
an established formula
we represent the
residents and some of us
understand the planning process
uh better than others
i don't see what an independent person
who perhaps has no experience is going
to bring now what council acetyl is
absolutely correct what it needs is
somebody with expertise but they can of
course be called as a witness
uh to the to the working group somebody
that can actually say
this is a formula this has this formula
has been agreed
planning inspectors
planning inspectors reports or whatever
so we need an expert not an independent
person
councillor thompson
thank you again chairman i just wanted
to add to what i'd said and and what
council of civil and councilman durham
said anyone can bring evidence to this
working group the working group can ask
for evidence from anyone that isn't the
same as making them a member with
potentially a vote on any recommendation
that comes out of it and
my understanding although i've not seen
anything written down is that this is a
chairman of a parish council
well if one why not
31 however many parish councils we've
got
we need due process to pick such a
person i actually think it's the wrong
we're barking up entirely the wrong tree
we get evidence from wherever and we
need professional advice that's
completely independent of the council
and the area indeed the district
thank you
right
councillor lagan
thank you chair um interesting debate um
the wording is actually a person who is
not a member of morgan district council
so it's not an independent person it's a
member who's not a member of morton
district council and i hear what people
say i think it could be easily sorted by
we either withdraw that from it or we we
give the person who the working party
agrees to to
come and no voting rights but i i what i
would like to do is
um
first establish that the
working group is set up
um which i think we've agreed
uh and then um i'll need to break little
two down
into uh i see you mrs stamp i need to
break little two down
um because i would like to populate
the working group with members
nominations um first of all
and then perhaps we will need to have a
vote
on this um
other person
i'll withdraw the
additional person so we'll just go four
four and four
okay
right uh uh councillor stephen would you
like to second that sorry chairman
somebody seconded me so we've got to
withdraw it
is that seconded
yes that seconded um council statements
um
i think i tend to agree with you
councillor stevens i i would have
thought two two and two would have been
a better more effective working group
but uh that is the council's apparent
wish that it's at least three three and
three councillor fluker
um i think chairman i you know i think
the prejudices as to why we want four
four and four uh can be seen tonight
chairman this is
clearly not everybody's favorite topic
what we're dealing with tonight and you
know i've been to work in groups
recently where there's been very few
people there and i know that a lot of
people work like myself work very hard
during the day and find it really hard
to fit these things in but we've got to
understand chairman that sometimes not
everybody can get to every meeting and i
think four four and four i think it's a
good number and i'd be very surprised if
they all turned up for all of the
meetings and now i can hear my friend to
the right agreeing with me so we have
two votes for that
so um i would i would say that four form
four chairman is is a good mix i don't
know how you're gonna choose these
people but uh i think it's the right
number uh uh councillor stevens you
hadn't you finished all you want to come
back
thank you
questions
uh this this group this i don't perceive
this working group going on in into the
next council i would hope that it was
able to report by november
i would hope but i mean that's something
that we can we can uh debate uh later on
councillor uh
uh deputy leader
because
you thank you um
well i have a reservation if we're
trying to populate this tonight i can't
speak for any other group or indeed
non-group but we've not had a chance to
prepare for a fourth person
okay well okay um
counselor
well chairman just in answer to to the
point that was just made again this this
is something that needs sorting out
quickly it's not going to run into the
next administration in fact my view
would be that the working group could
probably all meet for an entire day with
the relevant expertise and kill it off
in one foul swoop this is not going to
run on and on and on like a lot of our
other working groups and i would
certainly like to see it finished by
november uh i i would be proposing that
whatever happens that the working group
report back by november
um and i think councillor lagan's
i'm just i'd like to point out that we
seem to have a general rule that if
other councils want to participate in
working groups they can do so setting it
at 333
as in the recommendation um would still
allow other members to
contribute if not actually virtually
right um we have we have i think uh an
amendment to that to little to that it's
four four and four
full stop
um
uh
is that agreed do we do i need to take a
a
a vote on that all those in favor please
show
that that that looks
that looks this is for four four and
four
um your your mic isn't on council fluke
hi kevin
you you keep coming back you're only
entitled one speech but german it is not
a speech it's a question i've asked for
a recorded vote and and my dear friend
who's no longer on this council used to
do this all the time and yeah
um i don't know why you need one but um
there you are it's it's the vote is for
those in favor of four four and four
which i thought we got a um
of
a
majority support for
if it wasn't unanimous um uh miss bird
will you call the role please
i guess of course if you could indicate
foreign
stein
[Music]
thank you
four
oh
in the interest of time against
that's
is then carried and therefore the
working group will consist of four four
and four
and the member uh
uh
and and a person who is not a member of
morton district council we will need to
take a separate uh vote on that
um
is uh there any other
thoughts on this other person does
anybody else want to speak about it
chairman are we through it yes i know
but
i i had that as part of the main motion
so that i assume stills
is the the substantive motion now is
four four four and one
uh and one
uh
who is not a member of modern district
council have i got that right
mr dodson yes
could i refer to my report yes yeah
please do
thank you chairman
i'm i'm picking up from the the
officers report that was um circulated
to all members
um on this specific point
um and
point
3.6.3 of the the report
um speaks to this item so i'll just
highlight it for you and it's considered
that the inclusion of an external member
of the working group whilst possible may
leave the council open to a future
challenge to the five-year housing land
supply methodology
on this basis officers have recommended
the working group be limited to the was
nine
twelve now as you're saying but that the
working group is given the ability by
council through its terms of reference
to be able to seek independently
professional external advice
can provide further detail of why that
would be um an issue if there was an
independent or non-member of the council
who sat on that group um
i was going to go to the terms of
reference
yeah well i think i think we'll
sort the terms of reference we'll just
uh take a vote on this issue uh
councillor lagging you look like you
want to
speak thank you chair i've speaking a
lot i appreciate that the time just
interestingly um what would a future
challenge be
or could it be
so i think uh councillors need to think
uh in the the five-year housing land
supply um is more of a
uh a matter which is considered for
planning applications
um so the local planning authority's
conduct um in terms of determining
planning applications uh considers as a
material consideration the five-year
housing land supply particularly if the
housing land supply is less than the
five years prescribed by uh national
policy um so we have to i think
therefore
um
uh consider the
the the the legal challen that you could
end up getting challenged uh through the
appeal process
um and the methodology has got to be
able to withstand a high court challenge
um
because high court challenges can sort
of con you know
eventually the product of the five-year
housing land supply
could get into the high court could get
into the supreme court if it was
challenged any further
as i said earlier members there would be
nothing to prevent the working group
calling evidence from anybody they think
may be able to assist councillor swang
yes thank you chairman um
in recent discussions about the code of
conduct um the monitoring officer has
been
quite clear that
um working groups are counted as
having an influence on on policy
and it seems to be
even more extreme if you have anybody
outside the members
um contributing to
what would in fact be a body that's
counted as influencing policy so um
i endorse the view that it's very very
unwise to include such a person
officially on the committee we'll we'll
we'll take a vote on that now being uh
members is that okay uh uh mr quilts is
that the appropriate action to take
um
well yes i mean it's in the original
motion isn't it yeah it's in the
original and you've broken it broken it
off from the original but you can do
that yeah so yes so you've got 444 and
you're now deciding on whether there
should be a non-council member yeah i
think that's legitimate okay
yeah so yes chairman are we in fact then
voting on the second recommendation
little too little moment two except four
444 instead of 333. we're confirming
that recommendation we i thought i
thought we'd agreed for paul paul we are
now just looking at the other part of
the promotion that talks of a
non-district council person being a
member of the working group the officer
advice is
um that
that we should be very careful
and as i said the working group can call
but just give information advice
whether it be expert advice or
non-expert advice
um
council lagging council fluker
councillor darren thank you chair well
in that case i think um
it would make sense to actually draw
that part of the motion because that
makes things a lot simpler i agree with
your second uh
yes okay right so that that is not um
the case now can we look at the terms of
reference
uh yeah aren't you populating it um
well what i would suggest after the view
yes we'll we'll populate it with three
three and three
and then we'll
now wait a minute please
we'll populate it with three three and
three and then we'll see if the very the
two groups
uh can then um
uh come up with another nomination
but if they can't i would suggest
that they give the notice of the other
person
uh
to officers at a later date would that
be appropriate councillors
you know what you are okay
thanks chairman before before we get
into talking about the terms of
reference and
all
i just really
wanted to establish what this working
group is going to do
now this working group is not setting
policy
it's not coming up with a new method of
create of working out his five-year land
supply it's identifying
an already established and tested method
of establishing a five-year land supply
and applying it to malden
one one little one it was agreed that
the working group is established to
consider the five-year housing land
supply and that recommendations from
this working group come back to full
council for ratification well that's
exactly what i'm saying chairman yeah
well that's exactly what council has
agreed but it's not we
the working group is not coming up with
another a special mold and formula for
calculating the five-year land supply
uh i i don't know i can't pre-judge what
it would might come up with
well okay all
right um it's difficult to answer that
without
going into the terms of reference
themselves but that's certainly what the
the terms of reference set out is
confirming the methodology that's
currently used
and then comparing any alternative
five-year housing land supply
methodology that can be evidenced as
having been used successfully in other
english local planning authorities
yeah okay
uh
councillor stan
chairman but i did say that that i would
like to amend the terms of reference so
i don't think we should vote on it
now
not all what we'll do
is to populate yeah i agree the working
group but i don't want to vote
mrs thompson uh what are the
conservative nominations
thank you chairman uh councillors
channel durham morgan and thompson
okay councillor
i think he it is councillor edwards
councillor st siddal even
because i'm going to say the next name
too many s's
councillor stilts
um right now the uh non-aligned
people a group of uh group uh eight
non-aligned people
um
it is for the council to appoint but it
would be helpful to council to have four
nominations
councillor stamp german can i nominate
some please i'd like to nominate i've
got to remember the names now haven't i
i'd like to nominate um uh councillor
nagan councillor fluker councillor
spenceley
and mark
and councilman
councillor
right so we have the twelve names now uh
uh miss bird
um
which i'm sure i'm sure that you'll uh
have noted
um
sorry
yeah uh thank you right now we look at
the uh
we look further at the report
of the director of strategy performance
and governance and look to the terms of
reference
which are
mr
mr dodson would you like to speak on 3.5
thank you chairman
yes i think that all of the other the
business that the report
concerned has been agreed upon um so
yeah just speaking to the the most
sorry the terms of reference itself i've
set out under 3.5 within the report uh
proposed terms of reference for the
working group um trying to keep it
as simple as possible i think what's
really important is that there's a very
clear
terms of reference so that there's no
further
room for confusion or
or debate once the the five-year housing
land supply is agreed and referred back
to council for approval um
so i think it's it's fairly clear
what's put forward there confirm the
methodology compare any alternative
methodologies
potentially seek independent
professional external advice and that
could also include a view from an
external source on the
proposal that's put forward as a final
methodology and then for the group to
recommend the methodology
that should be used in future um to make
that recommendation to council
right um thank you mr dodson uh i see
you mrs stamp um
that's the four uh bullet uh points
there now mrs stamp you want to
not amend but perhaps ed
uh no i i would like to um put to
council that we amend some of the
wording chairman
uh
well
uh you have you got this written down so
you i have to me i i have i've got it
written in scrawly writing that i've
amended can i read it for members
because they may not agree with me
chairman yeah yeah okay all right so if
we go to 3.5 and forgive me if i get it
mixed up i've got it on confirming the
methodology
um or evidence so that's the new bit
that could be used by modern district
council to estimate the five-year
housing land supply including any
evidence-based circumstances or studies
regarding approved housing units can be
included or excluded chairman and then
the next bit comparing any alternative
five-year land supply reporting
methodologies that can be evidenced as
having been used and not challenged and
found to be flawed in any any other
english local planning authority so
what's that asking for
braces i think it is actually giving the
working group the the spec to actually
look at it that that could
and or may not
prove or disprove the five-year land
supply chairman can you remind me what
your alternative to determine
the word determine is
um
where is it to determine the five-year
housing land supply you oh it's estimate
chairman estimate uh now
uh um
can somebody help me the definition of
the determine uh or estimate which is
the sounder
wordy determined
you know i would have thought so
i'll change it then channel
the second bullet point uh what you
say i think is just belt and braces to
to what it's saying you're not
really
uh
yeah i mean i just want it to be more
flexible the working group needs to be
able to look at everything and i think
it's too tying down
we have to be the the group's got to be
trusted chairman yeah but but the the
bullet point says evidence as having
been used successfully in other english
and you're saying are not challenged if
it's been used successfully then it
hasn't been challenged or if it has been
challenged it's
overcome that council
thank you chair i can see what counselor
stamp is trying to do however i think if
we put this additional verbage into the
uh
terms of reference it actually makes it
more rigid and less flexible and i think
the way that it's written at the moment
gives more flexibility okay
counselor darren
yeah i ten
i tend to agree and i'm just going to go
back to what i said before everybody is
aware that there are developers
challenging our calculation of the
five-year land supply so the object of
this whole exercise
is to establish a method
of calculating our five-year land supply
that can be defended at appeal
in the high court or even the supreme
court as has been put that is the
objective of this working group not to
not to come up with a method that gives
us the number we we want but to give us
a number that we can stand by and
substantiate and this this from the last
and i think that the wording in its
existing it gives us the flexibility to
do exactly that yeah um uh mr stamp
you've heard um some uh alternative
views i don't know whether your
amendment was uh seconded but uh do you
wish to continue with your amendment or
in view of what has been said
chairman i think cancer swain wanted to
speak so i'm going to give way until
everybody's actually talked about it
because i think councillor siddal knew
what i meant
um and maybe you know what i mean i
prattle on sometimes instead of getting
to the right words yeah
that's why um thank you jimmy yes um i
think all that council
stamp has
tried to put into here is will be
covered
by the works of by the working of the
working group um
i perhaps i i have two words i wanted to
change in this and perhaps one of them
might um
you know allow the flexibility that
counselor stamp wants and that is to
change
confirming
in the first bullet point to considering
um which
would allow um all the
into intricacies that council stamp
trying to about um invade into this as
suitable for the working group to
consider well that's uh that's that's an
interesting view is there anybody else
who should speak
before i asked mrs thompson
mrs thompson
um thank you chairman i i do understand
what council stamp is saying um
but
my own view would be that methodology
would necessarily include looking
examination of evidence it's not a
separate thing
um and therefore what is already
here in the in the report would cover it
thank you
um yeah considering uh consider consid
uh mr dodson would you be happy with
considering instead of confirming
uh uh
but members have got to uh um
believe that they're not taking away any
of their flexibility and what they do by
uh by putting considering instead of
confirming
considering
okay do members agree considering yeah
right thank you uh so therefore i put
the proposed working group terms of
reference sorry
um
councillor lagan thank you chair i just
um
because daryl said something very
interesting about you know we're not
we're not trying to find you know a a
solution or a different way but we're
looking at the different methodologies
and i think the working group needs to
have that degree of flexibility to look
at all options that are used by all
planning authorities in the united
kingdom
and if there is another methodology for
that methodology or that that way to
actually come in a report to council for
council to make that determination i
think it's very important that we we
look at that
well this you're you're you're getting
on to doing the working groups work i
think at the moment
right
councillor swain
yes the other word i wanted to change
and i think we talked
about this aspect is to um in bullet
point three
to change professional to expert
uh i think professional could be
rather limiting as to what profession
we're talking about
um
i i think i i think that's a a good
point and and we need to actually
consider
uh what the alternative
uh is councillor lagan again yeah again
thank you chair i disagree i think he is
being an expert yeah there's a
subjective nature of what is an expert
well you know because i'm a highly
qualified health and safety professional
but i'm no expert in the whole field so
i think there should be definitely scope
for other people who
can bring something to the table and the
working group should have the ability to
go to other people to bring information
into this this is why i i was querying
actually um expert instead of
professional but was looking for a more
inclusive
word so if anybody's got their
theosaurus
andy
yeah or professional mr dodson
thank you chairman it's not to put an
alternative just to say i think
the term professional is important
because this needs to be definable i
think as councillor lagging said you
can't define an expert
it's it's subjective and this could be a
professional
it could be professional planning advice
it could be a professional barrister
who's giving us advice
it could be
a peer
so it's
it's clear we can get a range of advice
and a range of people but i think the
term professional is really important
because it classifies um the level of
advice and in
building on what um
mr winslow said earlier around challenge
if we've got that professional advice
then that should
ensure that we're we're less open to
challenge than we would be
will it um will it not suffice to say
independent external advice
that's more
or do you want counselors
profession tends to indicate that they
are qualified in some way so that's why
i think professional is important okay
is that is that the general view then we
stay with profession
councillor lagan sorry chad i i i do
think it's too limiting i mean yeah
you've made you've made your your point
on that yeah i'm just gonna say that you
think it would be changed well see i
think that's what i listen to what mr
rimslow says and and like i agree that
there could be challenges but with this
council has been challenged before with
professional advice
officers doing with the work they do so
i don't think we should actually be with
that thinking head on to look at what
what resources that are out there within
the district and i think it should be
district based because it is our
district that could be called upon to
actually offer some insight for us the
simple answer to this is um
uh
there has been a proposal that the
professional be
uh changed uh and there has been
arguments from officers and members
just to stick with profession
professional uh so those who agree with
sticking with professional please show
one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
those against
one two three four five six seven
we stick with professional then
uh that that's a democratic way of
sorting that argument now so therefore
we now have the uh the four bullet
points of the proposed working groups
terms of reference are they agreed
thank you
um
[Music]
mr dodson or sorry uh councillor
thompson um
is there any other matter on that
uh
on on this issue on this motion then
i'll come to councillor lagan to
sum up although we have taken all the
necessary votes
yes we have taken all the votes haven't
been chairman and no nothing further to
add but thank you for the opportunity
um therefore i think
the meeting
he's finished isn't it
uh i'll therefore close this meeting at
2019.
thank you
you